das ist schon ziemlich verrückt nach m87
dem ersten bild eines schwarzen loches
jetzt das nächste große ding des mega
teleskop event horizon
es ist ein bisher nicht gelöstes rätsel
eines bekannten gigantischen phänomens
im weltall und jetzt im forschende einen
entscheidenden schritt nähergekommen
jets die aus den supermassereichen
schwarzen löchern im zentrum von
galaxien geschossen werden die sind
bekannt doch niemand weiß warum und wie
sie entstehen aber jetzt gibt es eine
spur kriegst umsatz im future gegen zwei
mal pro woche spannende science videos
abonnieren kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
herzlich willkommen
centaurus a ist die nächstgelegene radio
galaxie eine galaxie also mit einem
aktiven schwarzen loch in das unmengen
an materie stürzen und zu einer
strahlung führen die millionenfach
stärker ist als zum beispiel die bei
unserer milchstraße und in genau die hat
jetzt ein bonner forschungsteams rein
gesund mit dem gigantischen teleskop
eventreisen die absolut spektakuläre
nahaufnahme zeigt die strahlung und
teilchen ströme aus dem schwarzen loch
im zentrum und die stellen einige
physikalische modelle in frage
ja das ist eine super detaillierte
aufnahme des teleskop verbunden
eventreisen kurz ehc es ist mit einem
kniff so groß wie unsere erde somit
konnte nicht nur die position des
schwarzen lochs das sich im zentrum der
galaxie centaurus a genau bestimmt
werden sondern auch der ursprung der
gewaltigen jets die dort entstehen die
spektakulären aufnahmen des
forschungsteams aus bonn zeigen unter
anderem hautnah wie ein gewaltiger jet
geboren wird der einem supermassereichen
schwarzen loch entspringt doch die
aufnahmen sind nicht nur super
spektakulär sondern stellen einige
theoretische modelle zu den radio jazz
in frage was offenbaren also die neuen
aufnahmen und was können
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von diesem blick ins dunkle herz von
centaurus a mitnimmt die spannenden
antworten auf diese fragen und noch viel
mehr gibt es jetzt bei pixum science and
future centaurus a eine aktive galaxien
die
etwa 13 millionen lichtjahre von uns
entfernt es identifiziert werden konnte
sich schon vor 70 jahren 1949 als einer
der ersten extragalaktischen radio
quellen überhaupt im radiobereich
leuchtet sie als sehr großes und helles
objekt am irdischen firmament in der
vergangenheit hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die galaxie genauer untersucht und zwar
im gesamten elektromagnetischen spektrum
nicht nur im optischen licht und bei
radiowellen sondern auch mit der hilfe
von infrarot röntgen und gammastrahlen
teleskopen wurde centaurus a ganz genau
analysiert diese untersuchungen hatten
gezeigt dass sich in dieser galaxie ein
schwarzes loch mit der 55 millionen
fachen masse der sonne verbirgt um das
im vergleich zu sehen das schwarze loch
im zentrum der milchstraße also unserer
galaxie bringt gut vier millionen mal
und das schwarze loch in der riesen
galaxie m87 etwa 6,5 milliarden
sonnenmassen auf die waage also so
riesen unterschiede gibt es zwischen den
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern in
den zentren von galaxien auch das
schwarze loch der galaxie m87 hatte die
fachwelt mit hilfe des event horizon
teleskops kurz ehc genauer beobachten
können die aufnahmen die vor zwei jahren
2009/10 veröffentlicht wurde
das war eine absolute sensation das
erste bild eines schwarzen loches und es
gibt eine weitere ähnlichkeit die
galaxie centaurus a produziert genauso
wie die galaxie m87 radio jets in der
fachsprache wird damit ein ereignis
bezeichnet das durch die
gravitationskräfte eines schwarzen lochs
ausgelöst wird schon seit langer zeit
wissen fachleute dass diese jets
existieren und es gibt auch schon einige
bilder auf denen zu erkennen ist wie
materie aus dem kern einer galaxie
heraus spricht viele details um die
radio jets sind aber noch unerforscht
doch bisher weiß man dass sich
supermassereiche schwarze löcher in den
zentren von galaxien von staub und gas
ernähren bei diesen ja mahlzeiten werden
große mengen an energie frei hier
spricht man dann von einer aktiven
galaxie alles was in ihre nähe kommt
also in die nähe der schwarzen löcher im
zentrum und sich nach dem rand dieser
schwarzen löcher befindet fällt in
diesen kosmischen schlumpf doch einige
der teilchen entkommen dem schwarzen
loch
wichtig hierbei die sogenannten
akkretionsscheibe des schwarzen lochs
die schnell und dessen zentrum rotiert
hier sammelt sich materie bevor sie in
das zentrum des schwarzes loch stürzt
zuvor heißt sie sich aber auf und
beginnt zu strahlen
doch ein kleiner teil der materie in
dieser akkretionsscheibe fällt nicht ins
schwarze loch und wird nicht
verschlucken stattdessen wird er in form
zweier starker gebündelter plasma
strahlen ins all hinaus geschleudert und
zwar senkrecht zur scheibe und mit
nahezu lichtgeschwindigkeit genau dabei
handelt es sich also um die sogenannten
jets diese transportieren dabei materie
und energie über riesige entfernung ins
weltall
doch der fachwelt sind sie noch immer
ein riesiges rätsel wie und wo entstehen
diese jets genau und woher stammen ihre
enormen energien jetzt also hat sich das
bonner forschungsteam erneut das event
horizon teleskop echt zunutze gemacht um
endlich herauszufinden wie diese jets an
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern
überhaupt entstehen eine frage auf die
es bislang trotz intensiver forschung
noch keine antwort gibt so nutzen die
fachleute insgesamt acht teleskope an
verschiedenen orten der erde
diese werden mit hilfe einer speziellen
technik mit der bezeichnung very long
baseline interferometrie miteinander
verbunden
zusammen besitzen die teleskope damit
eine auffang flächen die etwa so groß
ist wie die erde selbst dabei werden
radiowellen aufgefangen so dass es
möglich wird auch sehr weit entfernt der
himmelskörper extrem scharf darzustellen
und zwar so scharf als würde man von
berlin oder hamburg aus eine zeitung in
new york lesen oder anders gesagt mit
hilfe des event horizon teleskops ehc
könnte man eine apfelsine auf dem mond
erkennen die erreichte bildschärfe zeigt
somit details die kleiner als ein halbes
lichtjahr sind herausgekommen ist dabei
eine aufnahme bei einer wellenlänge von
1,3 millimetern das übertrifft alle
bisherigen aufnahmen um ein vielfaches
wie das bonner forschungsteams schreibt
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
die abgebildete direkte umgebung des
schwarzen lochs wo die jets entsteht
entspricht demnach der abbildung einer
apfelsine
auf dem mond der vergrößerung faktor
eine milliarde dem bonner forschungsteam
ist es somit gelungen einen
extragalaktischen radio zet auf skalen
zu untersuchen die kleiner sind als die
entfernung die das licht an einem tag
zurücklegt die aufnahmen sind wirklich
spannend sie zeigen zum einen den radio
jet der auf uns zu läuft schräg nach
nordosten außerdem den nach südwesten
gerichteten gegen jet der schwächer ist
das astronomie team kann hier parallelen
zu den größeren jets von m87 finden dazu
heißt es mit unserer beobachtung
demonstrieren wir somit dass die
fundamentalen beziehungen von aktivität
und jetzt für schwarzen löcher bei der
größenordnung gültig sind doch einige
merkmale die auf den aufnahmen zu sehen
sind stellt manche modelle zu diesem
thema in frage denn die analyse zeigt
dass die teilchen ströme an den rändern
heller sind als im zentrum
auch bei anderen jets von schwarzen
löchern wurde dieses phänomen beobachtet
doch bislang konnte es noch nie so
detailreich abgebildet werden dazu heißt
es vom bonner forschungsteam
jetzt können wir alle theoretischen jet
modelle ausschließen die diese rand
aufhellung nicht reproduzieren es ist
ein auffälliges beobachtungs merkmal das
uns helfen wird solche jets besser zu
verstehen
zudem gelang ein weiterer spektakulärer
erfolg denn die bilder offenbaren auch
die größe und lage des schwarzen lochs
von centaurus a der schatten des
schwarzen lochs ist demnach 14 micro
bogensekunden gros der jet stammt
demnach aus einer region knapp außerhalb
seines ereignishorizont ein foto des
schwarzen doch selbst ist den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern aber nicht gelungen
denn dafür reicht selbst die auflösung
des event horizon teleskops at nicht aus
um solch eine aufnahme zu bekommen
müsste der teleskop verbund ergänzt
werden und zwar mit einem radioteleskop
in der erdumlaufbahn um den schatten des
schwarzen lochs von centaurus sichtbar
zu machen müsste den berechnungen
zufolge eine virtuelle antenne von 8000
kilometern durchmesser her notwendig
wäre zudem eine frequenz von mehreren
terahertz dennoch sind die fachleute
sehr zufrieden mit ihren ergebnissen und
hoffen in zukunft auf weitere erfolge um
durchbrüche dazu anton zenz der direktor
des max planck instituts für
radioastronomie in bonn
das lte ermöglich uns nicht allein ein
blick auf die schatten von schwarzen
löchern
es untersucht auch den ursprung der
riesigen materie in galaxien relativität
und magnetfelder wirken zusammen in den
jets die aus der direkten umgebung des
schwarzen lochs hervorgehen wir
konzentrieren unsere forschung jetzt
verstärkt auf die magnetfelder in den
herzen von radio galaxien und quasaren
ich bin sicher dass wir die dafür
nötigen verbesserten methoden zur
auswertung der neuen beobachtung bald
beherrschen werden
die sensation ist da das erste bild
eines schwarzen lochs anklicken
anschauen und diesen grad nix umsatz im
future abonnieren ist ja auch ganz
einfach geht mit dem knopf hier unter
dem video also unter jedem video ist ja
der abo button oder einfach ihr drauf
decken bis dann